let's go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
270 area code caller from 270. what's
your name where are you calling from
uh western kentucky you said damon from
western kentucky go ahead
yes sir um well i was just calling um
first of all i want to point out
i'm sorry i'm kind of nervous here
that's okay [ __ ] biden and harris
are not my first choice at all okay i
think the worst
worst you could have gotten that would
have been biden klovachar however
after a little bit of agonizing i
decided i am voting biden just because
even though i'm in kentucky and i think
if i voted third party it wouldn't
matter much anyways i want to see trump
lose big in the popular vote just so he
can't say oh this was rigged i think
there really needs to be a great big
coalition
rejecting him i agree i i mentioned this
last week in that we have to run up the
score obviously this is an electoral
college contest
but given that we anticipate donald
trump might
either try to challenge the results or
claim it was rigged or whatever
a bigger margin in the popular vote is
better than a smaller margin so i agree
with you
oh exactly i didn't want to say as you
know more i guess pragmatic left with
leaning people
i do think one way we can screw up is we
don't need to shame
people who feel different we need to
explain to them
this and the best description i ever
heard and forget if i'm going on too
long make this quick
there was a left-wing youtuber who said
if you believe in what bernie and what
aoc stand for
and you look at the the amount of work
they put in and what they fought for
if you think oh we're just going to punt
this and let trump get it because we're
not get the right president
you're pretty much helping destroy
everything they work for because i don't
think biden
is necessarily going to become
progressive when he gets elected
but it's going to be a lot easier to
convince him and harris
to go for medicare for all and go for
free college and legalizing marijuana it
is trump and i think we have to
understand that
and we have to look at the down ballot
votes and we have to
look at this as a way of for lack of a
better term helping to infiltrate the
democratic party you know that sounds
really machiavellian no but it it makes
sense and i think
no matt you you and i don't think we're
going to get medicare for all because
not because of biden
but because most democratic senators
don't even support it but that's a
that's a specific thing you're
completely right that
with trump we get zero percent of what
bernie wanted
and with biden we probably definitely
get
10 and are in a position to get another
50
i mean listen it's just numbers right
and so the only real argument would be
i want to destroy the entire system to
build it back up in the image that i
value
but there's no historical example that
tells us that's how change happens so i
would reject it on historical grounds
but
you and i i think are on the same page
of course
and one more thing and then i'll stop
but i started with cornell west and i
think the best thing he said
is he said basically implied he's going
to vote for biden and
harris but he said that does not mean i
endorse them that does not mean that i'm
not going to criticize them and i think
we need to be able
to point out when they do something
wrong just like i remember when
you're you're a big bernie supporter but
when bernie did something you thought
was the wrong thing
you would not pay to say it
right uh yeah i mean listen uh all that
voting for one person over another means
is you think you're better than that
other person do you think they are
better than that other person that's all
i mean it doesn't mean anything else and
then we go and and we
do do the work all right my friend thank
you for the call i appreciate it